welcome to this video playing kappa
kappa Lauzon 63 yeah that's a new
opponent and he's going at four which
kind of fits more with laws and then
with cup of blanca for sure so let's see
that's the classical Dutch with reverse
colors hmm nice listener right now with
the extra tempo has decided on your
setup no I have not played committal
moves i wonder if i can go for five here
it's may be beasting 93 so he loves me
to play that move that's interesting the
first impression is that black already
should be quite comfortable if I get in
b5 against this III porn that looks a
bit strange but ok we will see what what
happens so I'm going to go nighty 7 ya i
bleep so we're maybe is going to go e
forward I'm not not sure about that one
and it's castle first I don't know if it
is not yam he has to do some of this in
a way I was wondering if I can do
something that's not a good idea I take
on c3 take on you for it would wreck his
pawn structure but well that's the only
positive thing about it my dark squares
ims so not a good idea I can play d4
though yeah probably deforms better
gaining gaining that space and just
saying okay I'm content with them having
decent control over the e5 square
it's so surprising I wouldn't wouldn't
have now that I did not expect let me
phrase it like that way because it helps
me to increase my control over the dark
squares actually Quincy five also might
be a move let's do that I am sorry yeah
2603 g5 will further were the two two
candidates so I went for one of the
moves there's this is an interesting
moment now I can play like you normally
there should be six or something and
then continue but I was also f5 which is
a more dynamic move trying to use the
fact that he is not so well developed
let's do that so it's debatable maybe
but definitely in playable playable move
Janet's of course better than capturing
okay now maybe at 51 the greatest idea
ever in retrospect that's okay yeah I
would have been better developed if he
had taken which she of course did not do
and here nothing special is happening
really I don't know where to put that
bigger oh now that's it's a strange
decision now I get a fantastic position
with the eternal knife down Wow check
and care and it gives me a clear plan
tried everything and win the end game
especially heavy pieces if I can get
those traded I'm just in fantastic shape
ok d3 now is this good if it takes with
the bishop I'll Chequamegon I chief FOIA
looks disastrous if it takes with the
pawn check it's not our not an immediate
win hmm
mmm take some things with the pond chick
I it's very good for black but I'm not
not seeing a direct win so okay I'm
going to play some strengthening moves
okay maybe I can invade via f4 you
cannot go Queen d2 because of Queen have
to check at least that looks very scary
Queen here I don't want to play c5 at
the moment because that's a great square
for my king so I'm just hoping that he
goes look everyone and then we then I'm
getting nearer to the desired end game
oh wow don't need no end game anymore
that was a very problematic position for
white anyway I think now it cannot
really avoid Queen loss Oh mate yeah I
was threatening that a three of them so
rue gave one Eric everyone was possible
maybe it still you have to do that quite
resigned I don't think the endgame is
any good yeah I think this is a funny
the opening is a funny case where the
early commitment to something by white
with the extra tempo is actually a
little bit little bit harmful because
now I know how he's going to set up his
Center and I reacted with 96 maybe you
should play d4 here it's a way to try to
make my peace look bad them transporting
to a stone wall it's not it's not
terrible for me I go Bishop f5 or
whatever it's just a normal position but
yeah maybe that's better than their
knowing if allowing the c5 business I
think here I'm almost certainly am yeah
quite quite comfortable already
it's difficult for y tu ya get a very
healthy central structure now take
stakes castles I am computer wants to
play c64 possibilities of Queen c7 or
queen bee six but again it's not a bad
move form yeah yeah yeah this this was
an interesting option but I didn't like
that so much my dark squares I can
terribly weak so it is probably not a
great idea I'm not quite sure what
White's precise movers if he takes on e
for more you can't even do that because
well the dark squares again if I this
position without g6 plate is quite okay
for black but with g6 plate it's it's
it's really not good so before I think
it's the simple choice closing up and
just claiming that the e5 square is
great I could have played quindi
six-year maybe I'm getting a temple or a
bit interesting okay I don't think that
this is bad but Bishop f4 is a strange
move because you don't want to trade the
pieces that defend the main problem
let's say I with with e5 so I was very
glad that I got this in and it's all
with the tempo and the brooke has to
move again Queen d2 is yeah maybe you
can go Queen d2 it's not like losing
material but ya don't do it this doesn't
look right the night wants to go to d2
yeah this is yeah f5 is very debatable i
was i was kind of tempted by this idea
and now i have ideas to really use III
quickly but of course it's not taking it
was a little bit of a visual thinking
with f5 yeah i think it's better to play
Bishop be 695 the way I played but not
go f5 so quickly it all God's very much
justified because of that move this is I
think basically losing the game
I don't think he can can can get a
playable position chatter his structure
is in ruin sir the pawn structure and
it's a terrible bishop that cut is
coming with the pawns that it's just
just excellent form for me yeah I went
b6 funny as a computer movement yeah but
it is probably good I mean I I looked at
this which is in this is very quickly
winning and I'd have two kills but he
can take with the pawn oops sorry can
take with the pawn and while this is
such a looking quite nice I don't have I
don't have from something that that
really killed them and this is really
what I want or what I would need to do
to have them in order to not go for an
end game and I really need to see a
checkmate otherwise I'm just going to
trade stuff and win the end game it'll
be six yeah now I know this this looks
fine yak going on to the dark squares
and irritate them a little bit Queenie
to now it gives me g3 he has to go who
have one though yeah look everyone oops
come on I'm going to of course just
shake it the green tags and then that
King g7 possible what is the plan here I
mean just trading Queens is the way to
win this going to see 5 with the King
picking up c4 it cannot defend that
anymore let's say i no understand now
maybe like here and then you can try to
oops sorry about that can try to put
everything on dark squares king of 6 and
try for a full-scale invasion Queen g3
g5g 4 and so on yeah that's probably a
pretty good plan let's say let's say why
does just shuffling him just shown the
winning plan
something like that is a good way to to
win this if he takes now this is not
going to end well the big issue is that
any kind of Queen trade is always just
just flat out using and again I'm I'm
getting getting the invasion invasion
going be sure this is it's very sorry
very sorry peace yeah i think the the
main issue here was that he went for
this move which is really not not not
playable if he does let's say maybe he
confused his move water possibly maybe
he had intended to do this and then then
night see for this looks far better in
comparison I mean like is comfortable
but I still have the relatively better
structure those are on light squares but
this is a position that why definitely
does not have to lose okay well thanks
for watching